there are a few real surprises is the
axe fell today on some fan favorites we
have the latest on TVs bloodbath okay
John's reaction this I'll pick from
Disneyland Paris with the caption hey
John Stamos Fox just can't read your
television show what are you gonna do
next
and now the don't fret Stamos fans he'll
be back on fuller house next season Fox
also pulled the plug on the grinder even
though it earned Rob Lowe a Golden Globe
nomination objection Rob's been tweeting
up a storm hoping to return but when it
became official he posted the grinder
was not renewed by Fox TV it was
unapologetically original smart funny
and had a murderer's row of talent fans
are begging Netflix or Hulu to pick up
the show but we'll see just a year ago
Rob was hopeful for a hit that's gonna
be a fun funny ride and Nashville got
the boot after four seasons a source on
the set tells ET some cast members were
pretty blindsided the cancellation came
on the same day as hayden Panettiere
announcement that she is seeking mental
health treatment for a second time
saying quote the postpartum depression
I've been experiencing has impacted
every aspect of my life rather than stay
stuck due to unhealthy coping mechanisms
I have chosen to take time to reflect
holistically on my health and life
wish me luck earlier this year Hayden
told Cameron returning to Nashville
after getting the first treatment was
rough to be honest it was a kind of a
rocky start for me and it's definitely
emotion
I just started I lost and I said like I
couldn't keep it together